hey everybody Jimmy here so this is a
review and an analysis of the Joe Rogan
podcast number nine six one that played
a day and a half ago with Graham Hancock
Randall Carlson Michael Shermer and
marked the Fonz so I got a few things to
say about this and in real quick if you
haven't seen the original podcast with
Joe Rogan where he's had Randall Carlson
on a few times Graham Hancock on and the
two of them together you need to go back
and watch those first because all of
those are a build-up to what happened a
day and a half ago which was pretty epic
so real quick where it stands right now
a day and a half after it aired on
YouTube it has just over six hundred and
sixty thousand views more than 15,000
thumbs up nine hundred thumbs down and
apparently that's just a fraction of the
people that have viewed it because it's
a podcast and YouTube is just a small
portion of it so then we just dive into
this let me start off with Michael
Shermer paid skeptic Run skeptic
magazine and you know how do I put this
someone made a comment on Joe Rogan's
YouTube podcast saying that how ironic
that you have Michael Shermer as a
skeptic when an all actuality he's just
an establishment guy in Graham Hancock
is the real skeptic because he's the one
trying to well he's a skeptic of the
establishment narrative that we've been
taught in school so I thought that was
pretty funny but when you have Michael
Shermer who's paid to do what he does
and he wasn't even able to speak to the
theory of the water erosion around the
Sphinx that just debunked the true age
when I think theory it's not really a
theory if you look into this yourself
the evidence is just overwhelmingly
conclusive and one thing I wish that was
mentioned in the podcast because he
cited Robert Schoch and other geologists
who have visited the site but there's
been hundreds of geologists from around
the world have that have visited the
site of the Great Sphinx and have said
conclusively that the water erosion
around the limestone bedrock is just
what's overwhelmingly conclusive and it
just completely debunked the narrative
that we've been taught about the true
age of the Sphinx and the fact that
Michael Shermer wasn't even aware of
this or able to speak to it I mean
that's interesting and to me it's very
very indicative of the fact that he
Michael Shermer is not actually
passionate about these subjects at all
he's just in it for the money I'm going
to give you another example he's never
even
been to the pyramids in fact it sound
like he never even been to Egypt all
together at least nine Gees a think
about that this is a guy that is trying
to debunk anyone that questions the
establishment viewpoint but he was
trying to defend that the oldest
pyramids if you're not aware the oldest
pyramids are the biggest and the most
structurally sound and have clearly the
best quality and craftsmanship and
technological know-how and the newest
ones the smallest ones the step ones are
falling apart there they're just it's a
complete D evolution of technological
abilities which makes no sense right
don't things get better over time and
anyways the point that Graham Hancock
was making with that is that well it
just shows that there was some sort of
advanced knowledge and over time that
went away with the Cataclysm and point
is this that Michael Shermer for him to
be so defensive of anything that is
raised or questions the establishment
just goes to show what a shill he
actually is and by the way I'm going to
say some really nice things about him
here in a second but for Michael Shermer
to question even the human migration
narrative when I mean if you saw the
podcast when that slide came up with the
Smithsonian talking about whether
there's evidence of humans being in
North America twenty four thousand years
ago and here he was trying to debunk
that when two sentences ahead of it was
just I mean it was very telling and for
him to even I mean guys if you're not
familiar there's Aboriginal DNA from
Australia in mummies in South America
but not in North America so you have
Shermer trying to defend this land
bridge from Russia down through North
America it's like man I mean really on
where I'm going with this is whereas
this guy's due diligence this is his
profession and I know he covers a lot of
different topics on his skeptic magazine
but really come on and for him and this
is a good point I'm looking at my notes
here for Michael Shermer to say to
Graham Hancock hey wait a second you
have these theories but all of these
Egyptologists have your evidence and
don't go along with it at all why is
that isn't that indicative that well
you're wrong you know Michael Shermer
for someone that does what you do isn't
it abundantly clear I mean I find it
really interesting that you can't
realize or know the reasons why the main
stream scientist archaeologists and
Egyptologists would try to refute Graham
Hancock do these people not have a
significant financial incentive to do so
I mean we're talking about people that
have had that have written books on the
subjects people that have had text book
deals or even written textbooks
themselves people that have been on live
TV people that have been tenured at
various universities because of what
they have suggested or as far as the
narrative of ancient human civilization
and when you have Graham Hancock coming
to debunk them with actual data and
scientific evidence make no mistake
these people their livelihoods are on
the line so of course they're going to
ignore and omit the new evidence and for
the in by the way some of these people
do not underestimate human ego and how
denial works it's a hell of a freaking
thing right and let me just move on to
one last point real quick about Shermer
which is him trying to debunk the
possibility of an Atlantis how many
ancient civilizations across multiple
continents around the world need to
speak of a land that existed that was
superior as far as the civilization goes
that was wiped off the frickin map you
know when a flood happened the same
period of time the Plato talks about the
same period of time that meltwater pulse
1 B happened where you have 6 million
cubic miles of ice sheets across North
America that melted in a very short
window of time that you know come on man
like really you need to see wood boats
and other things to back up the human
migration or support Atlantis or other
things like the one thing I wish that
was mentioned yet you know in this
podcast was that look you're asking to
see more evidence when you know what
we're talking 12,000 years which is such
a longer a much longer period of time
than most people appreciate because we
hear figures like you know the dinosaur
is going away 65 million years ago
whatever so when we hear 12,000 years we
don't it sounds insignificant but I like
to use the the example of the Titanic
which I've mentioned in several videos
of mine which is this nearly 50,000 tons
of steel and iron that has been under
the ocean for 105 years and it's more
than 50% disintegrated in just a few
hundred years it will be completely
non-existent now I know that things are
rode quicker under
water of course but used cars as an
example you leave a car outside for 50
years and you can see through one door
to the other the cloth or leather
leather seats are completely just gone
and the only thing left is Springs and
like the car I mean how many hundreds of
years or even a couple thousand years
would it take for it to just be
completely just absorbed back into the
earth and just non-existent right so
when we talk about a period of 12,000
years cuz everything's gone just like
houses how many decades before roof
caves in the Wallis cave-in and whatever
was made up of is just nothing but
gravel and dust and dirt and just
non-existent how many thousands of years
even if it was five thousand years
when we're talking about 12,000 years
ago guys you know for Michael Shermer to
not to completely just reduce the
significance of gobekli tepe and say
that we need to see more tools like guys
we could probably go to Sears buy a
toolbox and a bunch of tools just throw
it in the dirt and if we came back in
12,000 years honestly what would be left
even stainless steel materials what
would be left at that period of that
point think about that
and for Michael Shermer to you know
reduce the significance of Gobekli Tepe
I mean I think Graham Hancock handled it
well as far as well I mean he didn't
handle everything well I'll get to that
in a second but saying that look the
site itself is the significance that's
the big mystery you know when you have a
site with hundreds of pillars that are
enormous I mean never mind how they cut
and carved it never mind how they moved
the stone how are they able to align it
perfectly true north I mean it not to
mention 7,000 years older than
Stonehenge like I'm gonna I mean I don't
know anyone that reduces the
significance of that I would I seriously
question either their analytical
thinking abilities or their intentions
and when it comes to Michael Shermer
it's not the analytical thinking
abilities that guy's brilliant he's
incredibly articulate and the fact that
I clearly in my opinion he's in it for
the money
he's an establishment shill for sure you
know Shurmur if you're in it for the
money i you would you would make a lot
more money if you bought into the ideas
suggested by Graham Hancock maybe not
all of them but even Randall Carlson as
an example I guarantee you with your
level-headedness that your ability to
just not bite back when skeptics attack
you as we saw I mean you handled your
you had such a professional demeanor
like totally impressed by you I just
wish you would have more of a know
mind okay and if you were to have more
of an open mind and you were to be on
the side you know trying to debunk the
establishment which needs to happen more
people need to do this the narrative is
freakin wrong I mean have we not learned
throughout history just how wrong human
civilization always is right and you
know that then that brings me on to mark
diff'ent
so man what a fricking naysayer how
unproductive is this gentlemen for the
entire scientific community and for the
progress of humanity make no mistake if
mark mark diff'ent was born 400 freaking
years ago he would have been leading the
mob of naysayers and angry people that
were demanding that Galilei will be
tortured and executed for simply proving
and validating the theories set forth by
Copernicus that the Earth rotates around
the Sun sounds harsh huh doesn't it but
think about what he did with his hit
piece on Graham Hancock now Graham
Hancock he just read off a few passages
of it but if you read it from start to
finish I mean you really get a sense of
wow who and why would someone write
something like that it could be so
disingenuous is the nice way of saying
it it was a hit piece it was
disrespectful and was very indicative of
where his line of thought is but that's
not to say that mark DuPont isn't
incredibly educated and he held his own
against Randall Carlson however for him
to try and refute some of the evidence
that Randall Carlson presented involving
the massive flooding from someone like
myself who was really studied up on
Randall Carlson looked at his works you
know visit it you know clearly mark the
Fonz hasn't and you know for someone to
be so apprehensive against these ideas
and to try and refute them when clearly
honestly he's just off bait he's a bit
wrong on a lot of things he mentioned
you know it's like dude I think if he
put his his own ego aside a little bit
and just chilled out you know it would
help him a lot I would say the same
thing about Graham Hancock who by the
way I just love I would love to meet
this gentleman go out for a fricking
dinner and pick his brain or some
cocktails or or smoke a joint or
whatever Graham Hancock is brilliant
is he right about everything I would say
no but you know who cares
neither was Einstein or Tesla right in
the you know his works
and he in the research that he's done
for last few decades you know look I was
listening to this podcast in bed I
listened to part part of it one night
and in finished it the next day
yesterday and my wife was listening in
like why do getting so apprehensive she
was getting turned off by Graham for
being so upset angry you know he wears
his emotions on his sleeves but you know
to give him a little bit of credit and
yes I would say in the future I would
like I would love to talk to him be like
hey man you got a you got to learn how
to discipline yourself to not push that
not to bite back at the skeptics quite
as bad but that being said for him to
have been working on things that he has
for as many decades as he has to present
actual scientific data and evidence and
to be more knowledgeable than most of
his critics on the subject matter in
fact if not all of them to only be
called to be ridiculed shunned and and
called names are completely
inappropriate and just ignored how
pissed would that make you how many
decades could anyone stand up to that
[ __ ] before they'd finally be like what
the [ __ ] is going on excuse my language
so you know so some people were very
critical of Graham Hancock for getting
upset I see it both ways but ultimately
I think Graham Hancock handled the
subject of Gobekli Tepe very well and
you can see it in the comments I would
say at least three out of four comments
were overwhelmingly supportive of
Randall Carlson and Graham Hancock
diminishing the perspectives of Shermer
in diff'ent you know it's like it
reminds me real quick I got a mention
for Shermer to state that those cave
paintings from 30 40 thousand years ago
were more impressive or at least as
impressive as Gobekli Tepe I mean that's
lame that's where that's a ridiculous
comparison and you know so that brings
me on real quick to Joe Rogan I thought
he was an outstanding moderator I only
saw a little bit of criticism some
people saying that he interrupted
Shermer and they didn't like that no Joe
Rogan hit if it wasn't for Joe Rogan
first of all none of this podcast would
have even existed so mad props to him
for bringing this whole thing together
making it happen right but he held
people accountable Shermer in diff'ent
if it wasn't for Joe Rogan that
conversation would have been much much
different and you know people neat when
people are wrong and they're actively
rebutting scientific data which is
really conclusive and in
anyone that hasn't seen the prior
podcast and you're only coming into this
one the most recent you don't have the
full picture so Joe Rogan in my opinion
did a fantastic job and you know thank
goodness for this for this podcast all
together because regardless of where you
stand your viewpoint is on any of it
this is awesome for Humanity it's
getting new conversation started and
it's also painting a fantastic picture
for the masses to see what truth seekers
are up against it paints a picture of
what's been happening throughout history
where the scientific community is always
a gone against the new you know new
ideas whether it's Copernicus or Galileo
or or Tesla or the frickin Wright
brothers don't forget the Wright
brothers were being ridiculed leading up
to their first flight moments before it
don't forget what people were saying
most of the mainstream was so against
them not everyone but most so you have
to understand that you know you can come
forward with scientific evidence and
data overwhelming because it's
overwhelming and you'll still have
people is like don't even want to
process it and it's really unproductive
it's really unhealthy but anyways this
podcast painted a great picture of it so
I'm going to close this up but
ultimately the evidence is there that
the history of human civilization is far
older than what we were taught in school
and we were far more advanced than we
ever realized how advanced I don't know
how far back do we date I don't know
that either what I do know is that what
they're still teaching in the textbooks
about like say the cradle of
civilization the Sumerians 6,000 years
ago has been debunked research is
subject more on your own but definitely
check out these podcasts and Hey Joe
Rogan if you're listening please bring
me on your so someday I would love to
talk to you about so many different
topics spirituality DMT freakin medical
marijuana ancient human civilization the
Cataclysm you name it egos there's so
many things that I just love that you
talked about so anyways I'll leave it at
that I'm Ginny this is bright insight
like and subscribe leave me a comment
let me know what your thoughts are and I
many videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care everybody